منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والانقلابات العسكريه لا تعرف طريقا الى
اوروبا
العام وسلطات الالمانيه تلقي القبض على
عده اشخاص في مداهمات شملت انحاء البلاد
يشتبه بتامرهم للاطاحه بالحكومه حيث صنف
الادعاء الالماني تلك المحاوله بالانقلاب
على السلطه وان المعتقلين يعتقد انهم
شكلوا العام الماضي منظمه ارهابيه بهدف
قلب نظام الدوله الحالي في المانيا
واستبداله بنظام خاص بهم فيما تشير تقارير
المانيه الى ان مجموعه من الشخصيات
العسكريه السابقه اليمنيه خطاطه الاقتحام
مبنى البرلمان والاستيلاء على السلطه
الاف شرطي نفذ عمليات تفتيش في 130 موقعا
داخل 11 من اصل عشره ولايه المانيه اسفرت
عن اعتقال 25 شخصا من افراد مجموعه يمنيه
ارهابيه
القبض طال ايضا مواطنين روسا الامر الذي
دفع سفاره الروسيه في برلين بالمصارعه الى
نفي علاقتها مع هذه المجموعه
موسكو لم تكتفي بنفي سفارتها بلتبع الامر
تصريحات الكرملين التي اعلنت ان المداهمات
الجاريه في المانيا شان داخلي والا علاقه
لروسيا بها
المداهمات وهي عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب
المشتبه بهم ربما خط طول شني هجمات مسلحه
تستهدف مؤسسات الدوله
مداهمات اعتقالات واسلحه ظبطت مع
المعتقلين يتم استخدامها في الجيش
الالماني في ما تفيد تقارير المانيه ان
عسكريين السابقين هم ايضا جزء مهم من
مؤامره الانق هادئه وبينهم جنود نخبه
سابقون من الوحدات الخاصه